i went blind while i was driving
and that woke me up i was in a job where
i was incredibly
stressed and the doctors diagnosed
stress blindness or hysterical blindness
welcome to 20 just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford all she owns is one suitcase
meet linda cruz frontline humanitarian
leadership expert
author and inspirational speaker after
suffering temporary blindness through
stress
linda sold everything she owned and
changed her life completely
for over two decades she has been on the
humanitarian front line
working tirelessly to forge creative and
sustainable economic solutions that
empower and
uplift vulnerable communities around the
world to this day
linda still only owns the contents of
one suitcase
she has also created an innovative
platform race for good
where the best and brightest minds
students and business leaders
compete to solve critical frontline
issues with solutions being implemented
within days
linda cruz welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm exceptionally well actually michael
thank you
wow exceptionally well so let's start
off with that why exceptionally well
it's a great answer uh i live
my passion every single day um
i went blind while i was driving
and that woke me up i was in a job where
i was incredibly
stressed and the doctors diagnosed
stress blindness or hysterical blindness
and after that moment i decided as i sat
on the side
of the motorway thinking i was going to
be blind for the rest of my life
i sat on in my car terrified
and then i started to pray and i said if
my sight comes back
i promise i will find what i was born to
do
and about two years later i
actually when my children had were
following their dreams
i literally made that big move and i
changed from being
in a job that was i did really just for
money
um and i hated it made me so miserable
until i went blind and now i am
literally living my bliss
and my passion my work is my oxygen
so i literally feel excited
from the moment i wake up i wake up and
open my eyes
to the time i go to bed because my life
is full
of the work i do every single day yeah
well i think that that's a the dream
that anybody can can wish for themselves
that's
certainly what i wish for myself so
linda take me back
to that moment you're um you're blind
on you know in the car and you realize
that you need to follow your passion
what what is that search like for you
well what does that entail
searching for what really your your you
know your heart says you should be doing
you know i think what had happened to me
was i grew up in the uk
and perhaps in a country where was sort
of
almost programmed in society as to what
we do our expectations are
you know married children mortgage uh
great holidays and i was in that pattern
i'd done all of those things
i had got divorced when i was very young
and i had two children
but i still think i was in that very
that hamster will program
this is what we do in the united kingdom
and this shock and wake-up call of
of going blind was literally
okay i got it i just have gone right
off my path um i
reflected on how negative and miserable
and unhappy a person i was just by
you know observing my language and
my approach to life i couldn't say a
positive word about anything to anyone
so that search was then the
self-reflection was
okay the only person i can change in
this whole
awful scene at the moment is myself
so i worked on myself literally i would
never watch the news i would turn off
the news and play dance music
i said to my children we're not saying
no not and don't and if we do we put
money in the swear box
we had a good holiday that year michael
because our habit of negativity was so
ingrained
but basically half having sort of
changed myself in my approach because i
was still
in the same job that had driven me to go
blind
and but what i realized was the time
then
to really understand what my qualities
are what i'm good at what makes me so
passionate
and it was that moment of realizing you
know that i am
i'm a pioneer i'm an innovator i'm
curious about cultures in people
i love to be on the edge when i was a
nurse i was an emergency room nurse and
a casualty nurse and
an intensive care nurse it's within me
to actually be very good at operating
in critical situations he's a great
traveler
so i was putting all these pieces
together and i was a nurse of course so
caring and helping people be the best
they can be
was also in me and i was a businesswoman
for seven years so i had a lot of life
experience
but it was that reflection that made me
know
what the next steps could be or should
be of course
with the sort of work i do you never
really know
until you jump in and do it because it's
so extreme
right so tell me a little bit about you
know
tell me about the experiences you've had
while traveling one of the things that
you know it took me very surprised this
idea that you're traveling literally
with a suitcase that is your belongings
what what why is that what why why you
know make that decision what does that
represent
and and then we'll also talk about some
of the initiatives you've done
well to start with of course i didn't
sell everything i left to
see if i could
survive in very extreme conditions but
as soon as i started to do this
and i witnessed that all of my skills
and who i was
came alive in these situations
i literally said to my father please
stop cutting the grass for me you know
he would just say
house is fine the maintenance is great
and i'm like
actually dad i really have decided that
this is the life that i've
now found is the life i want to lead
and i didn't want to be held back by
things i just didn't want it
and so it was but it was the easiest
process
ever to just sell everything it just was
i mean literally in fact every single
thing i mean i
and that but the funny thing was when i
i sold the normal things like
you know car and house and paintings and
books
but then when i got on the front line
and really started to operate i
downsized even more from the suitcase
because i was carrying it on my back on
a motorbike
or on an elephant or on a camel or in a
canoe and i'm like i do not need that
extra pair of shoes or that extra pair
of jeans
so i can survive with the smallest bag
possible for at least three weeks
i mean it's i don't need stuff
i really do know how to manage with
almost nothing
yeah and how long has this been going on
for this
this life mantra
uh 21 years actually yeah wow yeah
21 years okay so linda you know within
just a couple minutes i just have to
hear about some of the craziest
craziest experiences you've had you know
traveling the world with a suitcase
opening yourself up to all these
different opportunities and experiences
that normal people with a lot of baggage
just can't afford to be
open to that so so tell me about some of
those crazy things that you've gone
through
well i think probably the most pivotal
one was in thailand after the asian
tsunami
and it was the most so i decided as a
humanitarian
that i wanted and i knew i could be of
service
after the some of the worst disasters
that happened on our planet
so when this asian tsunami happened i
was working in uzbekistan
and i saw my computer screen the
100-foot waves 250
000 dead and i knew i had to go
so this people often say to me michael
when everyone else is running out
linda is running in i am compelled to be
in these situations i didn't know anyone
i wasn't part of a charity i've never
been a charity
and still i'm not but when i got to this
area and i took a one-way ticket to
phuket in thailand
and that i witnessed something that i
must admit has stayed with me forever
you know that that level of destruction
where the tsunami hits
it looked like a nuclear bomb had gone
off you know cars on tops of houses
resorts crumpled like matchboxes glass
and debris everywhere
and then it got to a pivotal moment when
it was so overwhelming
i said to the taxi driver who was taking
me to the largest survivors cab
stop i can't do this it's too much
in hot and humid thailand the smell of
decomposing bodies
was overwhelming i mean just
overwhelming
and then i went to take some fresh air
and looked over the sea the cliff edge
and the sea was full of debris cars and
dead bodies
and i just wanted to run i just wanted
to run
and then i had a flashback when i was an
18 year old nurse
and there was my matron standing in
front of me and she said
nurse this is not about you
you are here to serve you are here to
make a difference
talk about pivotal i realized that
actually
all i needed to do was focus on the
people i'd come to help
and then when you i got to the survivors
camp of course that was another story
when you have these people who have lost
everything and they have no way of
rebuilding their lives
uneducated they worked in the hotels it
had gone all the hotels were destroyed
and a mother came up to me without
stretched hands and said linda
take my baby i can no longer feed her
and i look back into her eyes and said
no
i will not feed your baby but i promise
you i'll enable you to feed your own
baby
all of this coming at me so fast and
furiously
i knew in a flash
that what the best form of uplift
you can do post-disaster post-war
is to enable people to stand alone
my first mentor was prince charles of
england and he
said to me in a tibetan refugee camp in
india
involve the private sector they are the
most underused resource
involve the greatest leaders of our time
but he said
when they go to give you money unless
they're going to actively help you
leave the money on the table the jewel
is them their business skills their
entrepreneurial skills their innovation
their compassion
so straight away i used that model in
thailand
and got business leaders to find a way
that these
5 000 thai people could start to earn
money
immediately what i love about business
people michaels they never start
something unless it's going to be
sustainable listen to that sustainable
so they saw lining the coast where the
wave hit were acres of rubber trees
still standing
rubber viable for the next five ten
fifteen years
we asked the villagers are you happy
these thai survivors to actually
go back into the tie into the rubber
industry that your relatives would have
worked in
they said of course do you know the
costs to uplift a co-operative of four
families was only 250 pounds
and within four months they were earning
three times the money
they ever earned in the hotel industry
it wasn't my idea
so this is the amazingly powerful model
i started way back then
prince charles giving me the most
amazing uh
approach and i'm doing it right today as
i'm playing the race for good
with middle east students asian students
and business world
leaders all over the world and that's
just inspiring linda tell me about race
for good and what you're doing there
because at the end
you know when you're talking about
impact and you're talking about
sustainability and the
and the inclusion of the of the private
sector
as a mechanism to to to reach
sustainability
uh and you know don't give a man fish
tell them how to
teach them how to fish and that that
really i think exemplifies what you're
talking about here but
tell me a little bit about race for good
and how you're continuing this
impact across the world now well
what i realized michael was that the
mature experienced brain is wonderful
but you need the young unprogrammed mind
where
everything is possible and it's when you
bring the two together that the magic
happens because you challenge each other
you share ideas the innovation is superb
so every team in race for good has
students
and business leaders the business
leaders are the mentors the students
drive it
it's a competition so it gives that edge
of
you know are we going to get through the
league it's in a league
but we give the and we're really
embedding
sustainability entrepreneurship
leadership diversity inclusion
within these young incredibly brilliant
minds
so we give them real life families to
uplift
so a scenario the moment we're working
in the himalayas after the 2015
earthquake
is so much needs still so we'll give
them a real-life family
a mother father died in the earthquake
four children under ten
she works in the field and earns two
dollars a day for ten days a month
she can't feed her family and the
challenge is within two and a half weeks
to find
a sustainable income generating project
that she can do
right now
the solutions blow my mind every time
so simple so effective
and with my model all of the winning
solutions are implemented within two
days
this is not a paper exercise my team
are in the village really so the
students
and the business leaders see that change
and leave their own legacy can you
imagine
at age 14 years old
wow so just understand the model you
have people
in the location where where where help
is needed
you have these students and business
leaders around the world that are
joining virtually remotely
understanding the problem finding
innovative solutions
from wherever they are to then be
implemented by your team
within the place where it needs to be
implemented is that correct
correct correct and so and so where is
this today what is sort of the scale of
this and
and what is happening with race for good
today
well i'm in a moment of great expansion
so last year i was running race for good
across
asia amazing countries from china
india vietnam lao mongolia
this year we've started across the
middle east from saudi bahrain dubai
qatar but we've got to get bigger
i've already been invited to go into
latin america
and i'm waiting for people to approach
me and
invite me to play the race for good
within their country
it is such a powerful and transferable
model
right so this is my joy now because
we've developed in such a way that
it's fun it's exciting it's impactful
people always come back and want to do
it again uh it's a very dynamic model
and so what is this the idea of the race
behind it so i understand
the for good part tell me a little bit
about you know the
the the social element of it and
what these 14 year olds might be
experiencing as they go through
an activity like race for good okay
so for example they're schools in very
privileged countries whether it's uh the
center of bangkok or
in qatar who will start to understand
what it's like to live in a village
where you have no electricity
no running water no bed where you have
no financial security
no ability to access health care
so to start with the students need to
really dig deep and have that feeling of
empathy
right they need to understand the
religion right so if it's hindu buddhist
muslim because unless you do that
unless you wear the moccasins of the
community you will never get the right
answer
right they then start to learn about
sustainability and how
markets operate in that area with
probably very poor infrastructure
because what i'm trying to teach them
michael is that
for people like me who have worked on
the front line for a long time
to be successful we must make ourselves
redundant the communities don't need us
anymore
we're not coming in for the next 50
years to stand there and hand out
this is a hand up not a handout
right so we look holistically at the
healthcare
education we get the students to use
their incredible minds to design
new water collection systems how they
can uplift the health post
and the school but we're taking them
into a vastly different world
one thing they learn in bucket loads
michael it's gratitude
i'm not about poverty does not
but poverty does not equal unhappiness
ever
they're probably some of the happiest
people i know
um at the end of the day they're so
grateful that they've survived the day
they dance they drum they sing
they share amazing and that that's just
unbelievable
what's been the hardest part of all this
so obviously you know working on
anything
for good is is it not you know in
business terms it's not necessarily as
sexy and as
inviting as a lot of other opportunities
that a lot of people that you're
attracting to this
would have on their plate but but you
know as sort of the entrepreneur and
leader of this what is it what has been
the most challenging
piece of all this to put together
persuading companies that we need them
right because actually you know i think
for many years
business was put into a category of not
for good
right now i totally do not believe that
every company has the most incredible
people within its organization
right so my big thing and i've i've
worked
and i continue to work so hard with it
is to really
empower business leaders to step up step
forward
and join the race for good i've been
lucky enough since 2005 to know people
like richard branson
now what an incredible entrepreneur and
leader
i played the race for good with him on
necker island
when we were uplifting uh the caribbean
islands after hurricane irma
so i have these most incredible people
around me
but i still know that this call to
action from the business world
is so needed and necessary
and i will never stop michael
i just love that linda i think your
story is inspiring and
the the organization itself which i'm
very proud to now also be part of the
race for good is is just as inspiring
and i think that it's a
it's just wonderful what you're doing
and i i can't imagine
being able to reach these you know
understandings and
without the experiences that you've had
and without you know the the traumas and
without the
the compassion that you felt and without
those you know very
you know clear occurrences where where
you realized you know what what it's all
about and i think that you know
sharing this now with the younger
generation with 14 year olds
and giving them this space to go and
explore that compassion and empathy
with these incredible projects that are
being implemented in the real world with
real people within days it's not just a
paper exercise it's not just another
case study
it's perhaps one of the best it sounds
like one of the business one of the best
business schools
that you could hope for and so linda i i
thank you for the inspiration for this
before we leave
uh thank you for coming here i have to
ask you the most important question
which is three words you would use to
describe yourself
um pioneer
innovator humanitarian
linda thank you very very much best of
luck with race for good this is just
wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy all the
way from dubai and hopefully
as you're traveling we'll get to see
each other in person one day
super thank you so much michael take
care
you